now do you remember when I showed you
this example up here with this one and
the one that I've just rubbed off and we
found lo and behold there was a solution
to work for this one and it works
simultaneously to this one but it was
somewhat coincidental but just putting
in values we found one that lined up
okay
I only went up to three but I can really
easily make for you a pair of equations
and their solutions like offered a
hundred or something like that you don't
want to be drawing a table four five six
seven eight nine forever until you
happen upon a solution okay so this way
of solving things with a picture helps
us because number one which is a cool
number two you don't have to predict
where exactly the solution is going to
be the picture will tell you okay so to
begin let's actually just go with the
values they've suggested we should show
negative two to two
I think these are the values you'll see
there is that right okay so when you
have a look at the left-hand side I'm
gonna take these X values I want to
substitute ubi in right so if I put in
this one first
they're substituting negative two plus
two gives you zero if I substitute in
zero instead you just try to redeem
yourself why you so seeing zero and save
you got zero plus two which is and then
the last one is gonna be okay so what
I've got here you might have forgotten
this unit but because I can represent
this as an x and y I can draw these on a
set of axes so each one of these is a
point this guy over here negative 2 and
0 I'll write like that there's one of
the points 0 2 is another one of the
points and then lastly 2/4 okay so in a
minute I'm going to draw a Cartesian
plane I want to make sure however far I
draw I can at least draw these guys last
thing I'm gonna do on these guys over
here if I put
negative 2 again but to a different
equation what's 2 times negative 2
negative negative 4 then you take away 1
you go even further negative right fine
you put in 0 you're going to get
negative 1 you put it to you're gonna
get okay
positive very positive ok so again just
like with this table each of these gives
me a point an x and a y gives me
coordinates right well rather they are
commitments so this is negative 2
negative 5 this is 0 negative 1 and this
is 2 3 okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna draw my cottage of clay and I just
want to make sure it's big enough then I
think if all six of these points on ok
so let's do that one ok now as you're
doing that let me give you a bit of a
practical tip have a look at what I've
done in fact just put your pens down for
a second because this way I will find I
think I find this practically very
helpful when I do it so I want you all
to see this because will save you a lot
of trouble in the future
pens now just have a look at what I've
got in the world so far the first thing
you'll notice is I have drawn my country
to play nice and symmetrical it hasn't
just started from here and all about
yeah hold on the reason why I need to do
that is because the width of the
Cartesian plane comes from these values
do you see that X's are about horizontal
values and I'm gonna go from negative 2
to 2 that's a symmetrical isn't it you
see that if I were going from 0 to 10
it'd be different if I was going from
this negative 8 to 0 it'd be different
again right so to touch off these
numbers secondly what are these aren't
these three X's that are put onto the
graph right what what are they what do
they represent
and these guys 1 2 3
they're the points very good right there
the first three points I had me 1 2 3
now I'm gonna join them up in a minute
they're gonna give me a line but I'm
gonna have other points and I don't want
to confuse which lines which so I tend
to draw one with X's and then I tend to
draw the other one weird up
you're not wise I tend to draw them with
the pluses it's just enough so it looks
similar but I can tell them apart ok so
I've got negative 2 negative 5 all the
way down okay all right now that I've
got all the points on there you can
actually see the three points you've got
for each of these different equations
they join together to make the line
should ring a few bells from am two when
we did what those relationships called
linear relationships because they're in
a line okay so I'm going to join up the
dots now usually I say when I'm drawing
diagrams usually I'm at an advantage
because it's easier to draw I know it's
more time consuming but it's easier to
draw huge diagrams and just like it's
easier to draw it like huge circles and
make them look vaguely circular or is on
your page it's like impossible right
however in this instance for this job
you guys are a much bigger advantage to
me because I'm almost everyone's pages
you have a grid okay now remember I told
you that what I was looking for was a
solution that works for both of them
okay yeah which means they're presenting
yeah okay this is a big big idea so I
just need you to have your heads down
for a second
remember I told you that each of these
each of these right is a solution for
this guy right it's a pair of numbers
that makes the equation work but there's
lots of other solutions apart from ones
that I've written right like there's
ones that go further that way and ones
they go further that way by the way
that's what happens right there are
still more and more solutions and their
solutions between these solutions right
which is why even though once here once
here I've got all these ones to keep
between does that make sense I now
literally draw in this manner okay so
every point on this line right here's
one here's another one here's another
one every single point I can pick out
there is a solution for you in the same
way every point on this line and by the
way if you've drawn these why did you
label them with me this is y equals x
plus 2 and this is y equals 2x minus 1
every point on this line is a solution
to this equation so remember I wanted a
point that solves both of them at the
same time I need a point that's on both
lines at same time and there's only one
can you see it it's this guy right here
so I want you to label this I want you
to label this and I want you to say this
guy here souls both equations
okay in other words he Souls equations
simultaneously okay now very much said
you're an advantage to me because you
have a grid in front of you I'm just
doing my best trying to read off here
okay
now I've been roughly closed if I draw
this all the way down in here right on
yours you should see actually bang on if
you've actually drove the rule in that
kind of thing you should find it that's
three should be able to find it that's
three this you see just to the left of
it okay and in the same way if you draw
a line out of here you should find that
that's fine mine's a little bit off okay
so there's two reasons why the first one
is if you draw them accurately they have
no choice they have to make up there
correct but secondly I can know like if
your diagram is like mine it's a little
bit chunky not that trustworthy just
test it out let's have a look if I put
in just put on the sign here if i put in
x equals three what why are you are you
going to get out of here
three plus two which is what about this
one if i put x equals three into here 2
times 3 is 6 and 6 take away 1 is and as
you can see it solves both
simultaneously that make sense